The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: OK,
so what we're going
to talk about in this
course are materials
that have a cellular structure.
So they're all very porous.
And typically they have low
volume fractions of solids,
like less than 30% solid.
And we're going to talk
about different types
of cellular solids.
So one type are honeycombs.
And this would be kind of your
standard hexagonal honeycomb,
something like that.
We're going to talk about foams.
And I'm sure you've
all seen polymer foams.
Here's an aluminum foam.
We'll talk about other
sorts of foams as well.
We're going to talk about
some medical materials.
And I brought in some bone
samples, some trabecular bone
samples here.
I brought in a little tissue
engineering sample here.
And then, we're going to talk
about materials in nature that
have a cellular structure too.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about wood.
And I brought in a
piece of balsa wood.
I'll pass these
around in a minute
so you can play with them.
This is the lightest wood.
And I brought in lignum vitae.
This is the densest wood.
Lignum vitae is so dense
that it sinks in water.
And I have a couple of projects
right now on natural materials.
So I thought I'd talk a
little bit about those too.
We have one on bamboo and
making structural products out
of bamboo.
So this is like a beam
made out of bamboo.
And this is a piece of
oriented strand board made out
of bamboo.
So the same way you have like
wood oriented strand board,
you can do the same
thing with bamboo.
And we have a project
that involves this,
so I thought talk a
little bit about that
later on in the course.
So we'll talk a little bit about
the processing, how you make
these materials, the structure.
We'll talk a little bit
about how we do the modeling.
So we're going to start
with the honeycombs,
partly because they have
a nice, simple unit cell
that you can repeat and you
can analyze fairly exactly.
And then we're going to talk
about modeling the foams.
And then once we've got
the modeling background,
so we're going to get
equations describing
the mechanical properties, the
stiffness and the strength,
once we've got that, then we
can apply it to lots of things.
So we can apply it to
understanding the trabecular
bone, the tissue
engineering scaffolds,
or how cells interact
with scaffolds.
We're going to look at
energy absorption in foams
because they're good
for absorbing energy.
We're going to look at a
lightweight sandwich panels
as well.
So we're going to look at
all these different things.
And I have some slides I'm
going to go over today that have
more pictures of all of this.
And I'll pass this
around to a sec,
but let me go through
the logistics first.
So this first hand out has a
few of the kind of details.
There's two books that I've
coauthored with colleagues.
The one on cellular solids,
if you wanted to buy a book,
is probably the most
relevant one to buy.
If you don't want to buy it,
you certainly don't have to.
I'm sure the library has
multiple copies of it.
And the other more recent one
is called Cellular Materials
in Nature and Medicine.
And that's a little
more specialized.
And again the library has that.
So you don't need to
run out and buy that.
You can just get
it there, but let
me just mention
there's that reference
and it might be helpful.
OK, so let me talk a little
bit about the projects.
What we do in this class is
everybody does a project.
And I like for you to do it
in pairs, just so that you
have somebody to work with.
I think it's nice to have
somebody to do it with.
And the project
has to be something
on cellular materials,
but I really
leave it pretty open
ended what the project is.
It's really up to you to
decide what you'd like to do.
And to give you some idea
what people have done,
people have done all kinds
of stuff in the past.
So people have worked on
negative Poisson's ratio
honeycombs.
I didn't bring any
of those in with me,
but you can design
these honeycombs
so that they have this
property that when
you push it this way-- instead
of if you make the strain
smaller in this direction, it
gets wider in this direction
normally, but with negative
Poisson's ratio materials,
it will contract
in that direction.
So I've had people
do projects on that.
I've had people work
on osteoporosis.
I had a group once who
worked on elephant skulls
and I brought part of
their project with me.
So it turns out elephant skulls
have a sort of porous layer
to them.
And this is-- they
have these large pores
in the top of the skull.
I don't have a whole skull,
but this is part of it.
And what they did was they had
heard that elephant skulls have
these pores and that
the pores somehow
affect sound transmission
and how the elephant hears.
And so they wanted to
do a project on that.
And that was really all
they knew to start with,
elephants have pores and we
want to do a project on it
because it's cool.
So I helped them put
together this project.
We went up to Harvard.
We went up to the Museum
of Comparative Zoology
where they have elephant skulls,
which are like about this big
around, huge skulls.
And some of them had the outer
part of the bone was broken
and you could see
these big pores.
So they got some nice
pictures of elephant skulls.
And then they found that the
University of Texas at Austin
has computer tomography
images of all sorts of bones
of different animals.
And sure enough, they
had elephant skulls.
So they got the file
for the micro CT
image, which gives you the sort
of 3-D picture of the skull.
And then they use
that to 3-D print
small versions of the skull.
So that's what this is, they
printed smaller versions.
And these were just
a couple of slices
that I got from them
at the end project.
And then what they did
with one of the skulls,
they suspended it from a
wire, and they took speakers,
and they had sound that
vibrated the skull,
and then they put an
accelerometer on the skull
and they measured the vibration
response of the skull.
And they also made, I think,
it was a dolphin skull,
which did not have these
pores, and they kind of
compared the vibration response
from the sound for these two
skulls with two
different structures.
So that was a project
for this class.
People have worked on tissue
engineering scaffolds.
Often there's people
who work on food foams.
So one year, people
worked on bread.
They did bread processing.
They made bread by
having different amounts
of yeast, different rise
times, different ingredients.
And they made bread.
And I have a little-- I like
these historical things.
And I have a little thing
here I wanted to show you.
So the people in 3032
last year, last fall,
will know that I went
to England in November.
And I went to the Royal Society
for an editorial board meeting.
But I also went and
looked at their archives.
And one of the
things they showed
me was this article, which is
in the sort of an original, sort
of archives of the Royal
Society from 1600s.
And it's by a guy
called John Evelyn.
He's famous for writing
a book called Silva
about trees and wood.
But he's written
this article here.
And I love the title.
It's "The Several Manors of
Making Bread in France, Where
by General Consent, the Best
Bread in the World is Eaten,"
by Mr. Evelyn.
So here we have in the
Official Royal Society bread
making science.
And in fact, the article
was several pages long.
There was quite a lot on bread
and how you make it in France,
where the best bread is eaten.
So if you want to do
something on food foams,
people have done meringue
before, various things.
They look at typically
changing something
about the recipe, or the
composition, or the processing,
or the baking.
And they look at the structure.
Sometimes they look at
mechanical properties too.
So anyway, there's a whole
list of things there.
You can think of other things.
If you look through
the books, you
might get some ideas
as well for projects.
So what I'd thought
I'd do next is
I wanted to just kind of
give an overview of what
we're going to talk about.
And I've got a bunch of slides.
Let's see I forgot some
things, because I do that.
Books, yeah, OK, let me
pass some of these things
around so you get to
play with them too.
So here's some honeycombs.
I don't know if we can pass
all these things around
because it's a little unwieldy.
So this is an
aluminum honeycomb.
I like bringing toys in.
These are little
rubber honeycombs.
This is a little
ceramic honeycomb.
paper honeycomb.
And let's see, we
have some foams here.
So here's a metal foam
and a ceramic foam.
And this is a sort
of, not quite a foam,
it's made of hollow spheres
by centering hollow spheres
together.
So you can play with that.
And what else do we have?
We have little
lattice things here.
So here's a sort of
3-D lattice material.
So this has sort of
a cellular structure,
but it's very, very regular.
It's not like a foam.
So that's called a 3-D
lattice material or sometimes
a 3-D truss.
And what else should
we pass around?
We need to do the bones.
Here's the wood.
You can feel how different the
densities of the two woods are.
I would like these
all at the end
because I show these around
for different classes.
Here's some bone, you can see
of the bone looks like the foam.
And this is a tissue engineering
scaffold for generating skin.
All right, so while those
are getting passed around,
I'll talk a little
bit about what
we're going to cover in
the class with some slides.
OK, let's see, should
I dim the lights?
Would that be a good thing,
Craig, if I dimmed the lights?
CRAIG: They're kind of
preset, you can try maybe two.
LORNA GIBSON: OK.
Doesn't seem to-- there we go.
How about that?
That OK?
All right, so I like
these historical things.
So this is a picture of
Robert Hooke's drawing of cork
from his book Micrographia.
And he was the first person
who used the word cell
to describe a biological cell.
And it comes from the
Latin cella, which
means a small compartment.
So you can think of the
cells as small compartments.
That kind of makes sense.
And he kind of very
modestly says, "I no sooner
to discerned these,
which were indeed
the first microscopical
pours I have ever saw,
but me thought I had with
the discovery of them
perfectly hinted to me the true
and intelligible reason for all
the phenomena of cork."
So he's saying by looking
at the structure of cork,
he thinks he
understands everything
about the properties
of cork-- very modest.
But in fact, this is kind of the
foundation of material science.
So material science
is all about looking
at the structure of
materials and trying
to say something about the
properties of the behavior
of the materials.
And that sentence
kind of sums that up.
So that's why I
like that sentence.
So what we're going to do
is look at different kinds
of cellular materials.
We'll look at engineering ones.
And these we typically refer
to as honeycombs or foams.
Honeycombs have two
dimensional prismatic cells,
while foams have three
dimensional polyhedral cells.
And we'll look at applications
for the honeycombs and foams
in things like lightweight
sandwich panels,
in energy absorption
devices, and things
like thermal insulation.
We'll talk a little bit
about the thermal properties.
We're also going to talk about
cellular materials in medicine,
so trabecular bone.
We'll talk about osteoporosis
and how loss of bone
reduces the strength, and
how you might estimate that.
We'll talk about tissue
engineering scaffolds,
something about their
mechanical properties.
You may think the mechanical
properties aren't probably
the most important thing.
But in fact, the
mechanical properties
do have some effect on
how the cells interact
with the scaffold.
So we'll talk a little bit
about cell scaffold mechanics.
And then we're going to talk
about cellular materials
in nature at the
end of the course.
So we'll talk a little
bit about honeycomb
like materials, like wood and
cork, and foam like materials,
like the trabecular bone.
There's also a type of tissue
in plants called parenchyma
that looks just like a foam.
And there's some sponges that
have some interesting features.
And often, in nature
the cellular material
appears in combination
with some solid material.
And so it's sort of a
structural component.
And you can see
sandwich structures
in nature, leaves and skulls.
You can see materials that
have density gradients,
palm stems and bamboo
are examples of that.
And you can see materials
that have cylindrical shells
with compliant cores, and
things like plant stems
and animal quills are like that.
So that's kind of the
range of materials
that we're going to talk about.
And one of the interesting
things about cellular materials
is that you can make
cellular materials out
of almost anything now.
And this is really a huge
range of materials and lots
of different
applications for this.
So one of the fundamental
things we're going to do
is look at the mechanisms by
which the materials deform
and how they fail.
And we'll use a
structural analysis
to obtain the bulk mechanical
properties, so things
like the stiffness, the moduli,
the strength, the fracture,
toughness.
We'll look at how
you can control
the design of the microstructure
to get the properties that you
might want, and also how you
might select for the best
material for a given engineering
application in engineering
design.
So we're going to get
those three things.
So let me start by showing
you some more examples
of engineering cellular
solids, and in particular, some
micrographs.
So that you can see what it
looks like on a small scale
too.
So these are the honeycombs.
These are the sorts of things
that I'm passing around now.
The aluminum one, paper
resin, and the ceramic ones.
The aluminum and
the paper resin ones
are typically used in the
cores of sandwich panels.
And the ceramic ones are used
in the catalytic converter
in your car.
So what they do is they block
off every other cell at one
end and then the opposite
cells at the other end
and exhaust gas from
your car is forced
to go through those
channels in the honeycomb.
And the walls, if you look
at that triangular one,
those triangular walls
themselves are porous,
and they're coated with the
catalyst, which is platinum.
And that forces the exhaust
gas through the wall
in contact with the
platinum, and then
comes out the other end.
And they're ceramic, obviously,
because the gas is hot
and they need something that
has a high thermal resistance.
So these are some
examples of honeycombs.
These are some examples
of engineering foams.
When I tell people
I work on foams,
they always think
of polymer foams,
like polystyrene or something.
And there's lots
of polymer foams.
But you can actually
foam any materials now.
There's metal foams.
There's ceramic foams, and
glass foams, carbon foams,
all sorts of foams.
So those are some examples.
You can see when you
look at these images
here that the foams have a
low volume fraction of solids,
like if you look at say
this polyethylene one here.
Say we look at this
guy up here, then
you can see there's not much
solid, there's a lot of gas.
So the volume
fraction of solids is
fairly low on that foam there.
So one of the things
we're going to talk about
is how the volume fraction of
solids affects the properties.
You can also see on the
top left and the top right,
the top left one has
what we call open cells.
There's just edges
along the polyhedra,
there's no faces
over the membranes.
And the right hand one
is a closed cell foam.
So there's like membranes that
cover the faces of the cells.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about the differences
and the behavior of open cell
and closed cell foams too.
These are food foams.
So I've already
said you might want
to do a project on food foams.
And these are just some examples
of different kinds of foods
that are in fact foams.
And it turns out
the food industry
spends quite a lot
of time and effort
thinking about the mechanical
properties of food.
And it turns out if the texture
of the food isn't right,
then people don't like the
way it feels in their mouth.
There's something they
actually called mouth feel.
So it turns out if your
cereals too soggy, it's icky.
If it's too crunchy, it's icky.
So it's sort of a happy medium.
And food companies spend
quite a lot of time and money
worrying about the mechanical
properties of food.
This is an example of
showing that the cells could
be antisotropic, the cells could
be elongated in one direction.
For instance, in the top one
on the polyurethane foam.
And if they're elongated
in one direction,
it's not too surprising, you
might have different properties
in that direction from the
plane perpendicular to it.
And then the bottom
images is of pumice.
Pumice is a volcanic rock.
And you can see how the pores
are kind of flattened out
there.
And they're flattened
out because that was once
molten lava.
And the molten lava
was flowing down
a mountain side of a volcano.
And as it flowed,
it got sheared.
And the shape of those
pours reflects the shearing
as the molten lava
flow down the volcano.
And so this kind of sort
of stretched out cell shape
is going to give you
antisotropic properties,
different properties in
different directions.
This is the 3-D truss
that I'm passing around.
I don't know if it's
exactly the same one,
but it's a similar one.
And these trusses are
triangulated structures.
And we'll talk a little bit
about their properties too.
And then we also are going to
talk about some applications.
So obviously, these
materials are mostly air.
And that gives
them a low weight.
And that means they're often
used in structural sandwich
panels as the core of the panel.
And these panels have
stiff faces separated
by a lightweight core.
And the idea is to make it
a little bit like an I-beam.
So the way you have the
flanges on the I-beam,
the faces are like the
flanges, and the porous core
is like the web of the I-beam.
They can also undergo
large deformations
at relatively low stress.
And that means they can
absorb a lot of energy.
So if you think of the energy
as the area under the stress
strain curve, if there's big
strains and big deformations,
then there's going
to be a large area.
And that sort of
energy absorption
occurs at a fairly low stress.
So typically, when you
want to absorb energy,
it's not just how much
energy you want to absorb.
You have to do it without
actually breaking the thing
you're trying to protect.
So you don't want to generate
high stresses as you go along,
and foams are good at this.
Foams are also good at
being thermal insulators.
They have a low
thermal conductivity.
And that's because they're
largely made of gas
and the gas has a lower
conductivity than the solids.
So that gives them a
lower conductivity.
And they have a
large surface area.
And the smaller the pore
size, the bigger the
surface area per unit volume.
And that makes them
good for things
like carriers for catalysts.
And that's why they're used for
these catalytic converters too.
OK, so here's some examples of
cellular materials in medicine.
So here's some examples
of trabecular bone.
Trabecular bone exists at
the ends of your long bones.
So say in your hip
or in your knee.
It also exists in your vertebrae
in the middle of the spine
in the vertebrae there.
And it also exists
in your skull.
And you can see it's
a porous type of bone.
It looks very similar to
the foams and the sorts
of mechanical models
we make for foams can
be applied to the bone as well.
And so that's one
of the things we're
going to do later in the course.
These are two slides
showing what happens
when people get osteoporosis.
The left hand slide is
from a 55-year-old female
to the same bone,
the same slice.
And the right hand one is
from an 86-year-old female.
This thing here,
row star over row S,
that's the relative density,
the density of the bone
divided by the solid
that it's made from.
That's the same as the
volume fraction of solids.
And so on the normal bone on
the left it's about 17% solid.
And on the osteoporotic bone
on the right it's, about 7%.
So you can kind of see the
bone density has gotten lower,
partly by thinning
of the struts,
but partly by resorption
of the struts, as well.
And obviously the
one on the right
is going to have a
lot lower strength
than the one on the left.
These are micro
CT images of bone.
And again, you can
see how the structure
looks different at different
relative densities.
The one on the left is sort
of in the middle at around 11%
dense.
The one in the middle
is the most dense 25%.
And the one on the
right is 6% dense.
So it's not too surprising
that the one on the right
would have a much lower
strength from the other ones.
And we'll look at how
we can model that.
This is just showing
some deformation in bone.
I have a colleague,
Ralph Mueller
who's got a micro
CT machine, which
allows you to do compression
tests in the micro CT.
So he can make
these sort of images
where he scans it
at zero strain.
He compresses it a little bit.
He scans it again.
He compresses it a bit more.
And he these are
stills from his images,
but he makes
animations from this.
And if you look at
the top right up here,
you see these struts here.
They're pretty
straight in this one.
They're a little bent and
starting to buckle here.
And then if you look at
that one strut there,
you can see how it's
buckled right over.
So you can look at the
deformation mechanisms
by looking at the CT scans
and things like that.
People are starting
to think about using
metal foams for coatings
of orthopedic implants.
So one of the
issues with implants
is that say you have a hip
implant or a knee implant,
you remove the bone
that's preexisting,
and then you replace it
with some sort of implant.
Typically, the
implant has a stem
that fits into the
hollow part of the bone
and then has a sort
of joint piece to it
that fits into the joint.
And you can get some loosening
of the stem in the remaining
bone.
And one idea is that you use
porous coatings to minimize
that.
And right now, typically
what they do is center beads,
metal beads on to the stem.
And another idea is maybe
you could use a metal foam.
And these are some different
types of metal foams
that people are looking at.
Another type of cellular
material in medicine
is a tissue
engineering scaffold.
And this just shows
some different examples
made by different processes.
And we'll talk more about
these later on in the course.
This one here at the
top left is a collagen
based one made by a
freeze drying process.
And I don't know if you
saw MIT's website yesterday
and today, Ioannis Yannas was
the one who developed this.
And he's just being inducted
into the National Inventors
Hall of Fame.
And this is what he
really was inducted
for is he's invented
a skin-- well,
he calls it a dermal
regeneration template
for regenerating skin, mostly
in people with serious burns.
Then these are some other
sorts of scaffolds that are
made by different processes.
This is by a sort of rapid
prototyping process here.
The bottom two, these
are kind of interesting.
These are actually the
extracellular matrix
in the body.
And they've had all the
cells removed from it.
So these tissue
engineering scaffolds
are really designed to mimic
the extracellular scaffold
in your body or extracellular
matrix in your body.
And you can see how when
you remove the cells,
the structure of
those two things
looks a lot like a
closed cell foam.
So that's the kind of structure
you're trying to replicate.
We'll look a bit
at cell mechanics.
This is a cell
contraction of a scaffold.
So here these sort of
very thin transparent bits
of the collagen based scaffold,
and this is a fiber blast on it
right here.
And I had a student,
Toby [? Fryman, ?]
who worked with me and
Ioannis Yannas on this.
And you can see from the
video the cell is actually
contract in the scaffolding
making it deform.
And you can
calculate what forces
the cell must be
imposing on the scaffold
by knowing something about
the geometry of the struts
and how the cells attached.
And then it's going
a little bit more.
So we'll talk more about that.
And then there's a
final picture down here,
where you can see these
two, the two points
up here and down here have now
been brought pretty much right
together.
So we'll talk about
that in more detail.
We've also done studies
on cell attachment
and how that attachment rate or
the amount of cells that attach
is related to the
surface area, the surface
area per unit volume.
So these are just
some tests from that
done by [? Fergal ?] O'Brien,
a post-doc that worked with me.
We've also done some
studies on cell migration.
And Brendan Harley was
the student who did this.
And he stained the
cells with one stain
and he stained the scaffold
with something else.
So red are the scaffold
and green are the cells.
And then he used a confocal
microscope to track the cells.
And he tracked the cells and
where they moved versus time.
And if he has the location
at different times
he can get the velocity.
And one of the
things he did was he
changed the stiffness
of the scaffold
and he found that the
migration speed depended
on how stiff the scaffold was.
So he was looking at
sort of interactions
between mechanical
properties of the scaffold
and behaviors like
cell migration.
And then we're going to
look at materials in nature.
So here is wood.
So you can see the
cellular structure of wood.
It's a lot like the honeycombs.
It has sort of a
prismatic structure.
That one happens to be cedar,
but other woods look similar.
Now, this is balsa wood.
And this is showing just
how the balsa deforms.
I think this was loaded
from top to bottom.
And this is at zero load.
And then this is more load,
and more load, and more load.
And if you look
at that cell there
with this little kind
of tear in it here,
that's the same as
the cell down here,
and that's the tear there.
So you can see how the cell
walls bend and how they deform.
And you can model that
using the honeycomb models.
This is just another image
showing actual failure of wood,
buckling of the cell walls.
This is cork.
So these are modern scanning
electron micrograph of cork.
And one of the
interesting things
is the cork cells have
these little corrugations.
You see how they're
not flat, they
have little kind of
wrinkles in them.
And that gives rise to sort
of an interesting property
of cork.
If you take cork
and you load it.
So here we were pulling it in
the direction of these arrows,
pulling it like along
this direction here.
And again, this is
the same set of cells.
That tear there is the
same as that tear there.
And you see all these
little corrugations here,
they've all straightened out
when we're pulling on it.
And the Poisson's ratio
of the cork is zero.
It's kind of like a bellows.
Like if you had an
old camera, or you
have an accordion bellows.
If you pull the
bellows in and out,
it doesn't get any wider
this way or the other way.
You're just sort of
opening the bellows
and closing the bellows.
And the cork cells are doing
kind of the same thing.
And it gives them this
Poisson's ratio of zero.
Which it happens is
one of the things that
makes it easy to get the
cork into your wine bottle,
because as you're pushing
on it, it's not pushing out
in all directions.
This is only for
this one direction,
but it's not pushing
out in all directions.
These are parenchyma
cells in plants,
in carrots and potatoes.
All those little blobs in the
potato, those are starch blobs.
This is called a Venus
flower basket sponge,
and Joanna Aizenberg,
at Harvard,
has studied this quite a lot.
This has a
hierarchical structure.
If you look at
the overall sponge
and then you look at each
of the sort of struts
that make up the
lattice, that too
has a hierarchical structure.
And she's looked at the optical
properties of this glass
sponge.
It's kind of a beautiful thing.
And then there's some cellular
structures in nature as well.
There's sandwich structures.
There's density gradients.
And there's tubes
with a cellular core.
So here's some examples of that.
Here's the iris leaf,
you know the iris plant
has these long kind of leaves
that stand up like this.
And it's just like
a sandwich panel.
The parenchyma are kind of
like a foam in the middle here.
And there's very
dense fibers called
sclerenchyma that run up and
down the length of the leaf.
And they're like fibers
in a fiber composite.
And here's a bull rush
or a cat tail leaf.
And they're like
little I-beams almost.
It's like a whole series
of little I-beams.
And again that's sort
mechanically efficient.
These are examples of sandwich
structures in bird skulls.
Some of you know I'm a birder.
So I sort of sneak in bird
stuff from time to time.
But you can see how these birds
skulls are all sandwich panels,
and obviously birds want
to minimize their weight
for flight.
And this is one of the
ways that they do that.
This is a horseshoe crab,
sort of similar kind of thing.
This is from Mark
Myers in San Diego.
He did a study on the crab
in its shell as a sandwich.
And this is the ever
so handsome cuttlefish.
And the cuttlefish has something
called a cuttlefish bone.
This is the bone
here and the bone
is made up of these kind of
sandwich type structures.
The cuttlefish is related to
octopus and squid and things
like that.
And it's hard to see
in this picture here,
but these little things here are
actually like little tentacles.
There's several tentacles
that it eats stuff with.
The cuttlefish is
actually a mollusk.
All those things are mollusks.
It's called a fish, but
it's not really a fish.
And here's an example of
a natural material that
has a radial density gradient.
Have you ever noticed
if you look at a palm,
like you see those pictures of
Hollywood in LA, and the palm
trees, you know,
they line the street.
But they're all about
the same diameter
from the bottom to the top.
And when you think of like an
oak tree, it's not like that.
It's big diameter at the bottom,
skinny diameter at the top.
So when wood grows, the wood has
more or less the same density
in the bottom and at the top.
So as it's growing, the density
is more or less the same.
And it resists the bigger
loads from getting taller
by adding circumference.
So it gets wider and wider
as it gets older and older.
But palms don't do that.
They come out of the
ground a certain diameter.
And most palms just
grow that same diameter.
As they get taller
and taller, you
can imagine there's wind forces,
and different kinds of forces
are on it, the stresses
get bigger and bigger.
And the way they resist
those is that the cell walls
get thicker, and
they preferentially
get thicker on the outside.
And if you think of
moment of inertia,
remember moment of
inertia is increased
more with the material
on the outside of a beam.
And that's kind of
what the palm is doing.
So if you look at young cell
walls and old cell walls,
here's some SCM
pictures of young ones
and it's sort of skinny.
And SCM pictures of older
ones, and the cell wall
has gotten thicker.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about that.
And it turns out, this is
an incredibly efficient way
to deal with getting taller and
needing to resist bigger loads.
Another material that has
a radial density gradient
is bamboo.
So this again shows these sort
of dense sclerenchyma fibers.
Do you see these kind
of dense parts here?
And you can see there's
not very many of them here.
And there's more and more as you
get towards the outside there.
So there's a density
gradient there.
So we'll talk about that.
And some plant materials
have a cylindrical shell
with a compliant core.
Plant stems or commonly like.
This is a milkweed stem.
And you can see it's got
these sort of fibers that
are almost completely dense.
And then a sort of
lower density core,
cellular core, here, and
a void in the very middle.
And you can show that that core
helps prevent local buckling.
So if you take a drinking
straw and you bend it,
you get that kinking
kind of failure.
You can show that
having this sort of foam
like core in the middle
helps to resist that.
Imagine you have
a drinking straw
and now you put
foam in the middle.
It's going to be harder to
get it to kink like that.
So that's what the
plants are doing.
Animal quills do the same thing.
That's a porcupine
and a hedgehog quill.
And all of this stuff
is in these two books.
So it doesn't really
matter to me if you go out
and buy the book.
I don't make very many
much money on these books.
So this is not an
income producing thing.
But those are the books
that all these pictures
have been taken from.
All right, so I
think that's my sort
of introduction to the class.
Are there any questions
about how we're organized
or what we're going to be doing?
Are we good?
It's OK?
OK.
So then I think what I'm going
to do for the rest of the time
is start the next section of the
course which is on processing
of cellular materials.
Now, I have another
little hand out here.
So I don't know if I'll remember
to do this for every lecture,
but I like to have a
little outline, that
partly makes me be organized.
So it's just a little
outline for the lecture.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: You
asked me to do what?
AUDIENCE: Put the
room light back up.
LORNA GIBSON: Put the what up?
AUDIENCE: Lights.
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, the lights.
I'm going have another
set of slides though.
So let me get out
of the intro slides.
I know I have another
set of slides.
So I'm going to just
leave the screen up.
And kind of put stuff
on the board and talk
about the slides.
AUDIENCE: That's fine.
LORNA GIBSON: You're good?
OK.
So I wanted to talk a
little bit about processing
of cellular solids and
then, next time we'll
start talking about
the structures.
It seemed good to talk
about the processing
before we got to the structure.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about honeycombs
and how they make
honeycombs, and then foams,
and then lattice materials.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The slide you're
showing with the the shell
with the foam
inside it, are there
techniques for analysis of it?
LORNA GIBSON:
Well, I don't think
we're going to get into
all the gory details,
but I can certainly
give you references.
That's something that one of
my students did at one point.
And in fact, I've been
collaborating with Jennifer
Lewis up at Harvard
and she has a student
who's making sort of
cylindrical shells
with foams out of ceramic foam.
So he's 3-D printing sort
of with coaxial nozzles
a cylindrical shell
that's pretty solid.
And then a ceramic
foam on the inside.
And that's one of the things
he's playing around with.
So he's looking at
ways you might make
engineering versions of that.
So I wanted to start with
looking at honeycombs
and how they make honeycombs.
And I thought what I'd do
is I've got some slides.
And I'm going to talk
about the slides.
And then I'll put some notes on
the board to kind of describe
what we're doing, OK?
So this is the first sort
of slide on the honeycombs.
And the two main
techniques that they're
made by, especially
those aluminum honeycombs
and paper honeycombs that I
passed around, one technique
is an expansion process.
So what they do is they take
flat sheets of some metal,
say aluminum, and they put
little stripes of glue on it
in different places.
So these little kind
of specialty things
are where the glue goes.
And then they
stack those guys up
in a sort of
particular arrangement.
And then what they do is
they pull it all apart, kind
like a paper doll thing.
They pull it all apart and
when they pull it apart,
they get the hexagonal shape.
So let me just show on the
board how you do the gluing
and how that works.
So they would start
with some sheets.
Say we start with
two sheets like that.
They'd put some glue
down, say there.
And then there's a gap.
And then they put glue on
the opposite side over there.
And then there's another gap.
And then they put glue there.
And then they do
the same positions
but the opposite sides
on the next sheet.
So they do that.
And then if you glue
those together-- well,
let me do another one.
Maybe do a couple more.
So then if I do one like
that, it's glued there,
and there, and there.
That guy gets there,
and there and there.
And when glue that-- when
you push that together
and then take it
apart, you've got
something that looks like this.
So say I call that one,
two, three, and four.
Then this would be 2 and 3.
OK, so this thing here is that.
Where it's not glued,
you get them doing that.
And then it's glued
again down here.
And so you get this
kind of pattern.
And one of the things
about these honeycombs
that are made by the expansion
process is these inclined walls
have a thickness t.
And because there's
two sheets up here,
the vertical walls
have a thickness 2t.
So that's typically what you
see in the commercial honeycombs
that are made by this way.
And this process is used
for aluminum honeycombs,
for paper resin honeycombs,
for Kevlar honeycombs.
And I'll just say note that the
inclined walls have a thickness
t, and the vertical
walls are 2t.
So that's the expansion process.
And the process that's
commonly used for honeycombs
is called a corrugation process.
And for the corrugation
process, it's
just like the lower
schematic here shows.
You take a flat sheet.
So you've got a roll
of a flat sheet.
And you've got some rollers
that have the right shape
to give you the corrugated
profile that you want.
You pass the sheet
through the rolls
and you get
individual sheets out.
And each sheet is kind
of a half hexagon.
And then you put
the sheets together
and that forms
the whole hexagon.
So you have a flat
sheet that's fed
through a shaped wheel to
form half hexagonal sheets,
which you then bond together.
And it's the same kind of
thing that the inclined
walls have thickness t
and the vertical walls
have thickness 2t.
And this corrugation
process, you
can only really
use it in materials
that you can deform
a fairly large amount
to get the corrugations.
So typically, this
is for metals.
And aluminum is probably
the most common metal
that this is used for.
AUDIENCE: How are the corrugated
sheets attached to each other?
LORNA GIBSON: I think they're
just bonded with epoxy.
Yeah, so obviously if you wanted
to use it for high temperature
performance-- you know,
all of these things
are bonded with some sort of
epoxy or some sort of resin.
So there's an
issue if you wanted
to use it higher temperatures.
So another process that's used
to make ceramic honeycombs
is an extrusion process.
And you just take
a ceramic slurry
and you pass it through a die.
And you can make a ceramic
honeycomb by doing that.
And I believe
that's how they make
the ceramic honeycombs
I passed around,
the catalytic converter ones.
Other techniques involve
rapid prototyping.
You can 3-D print honeycombs.
And Jennifer Lewis has a
project on 3-D printing
of honeycombs up at Harvard.
And one of the interesting
things they're looking at
is not just printing with an
ink, but printing with a fiber
reinforced ink.
So they're making cell
walls of the honeycomb that
are fiber reinforced.
And one of the tricks is trying
to orient the fibers in the way
that you want them
to be oriented.
So there's rapid prototyping
techniques as well.
You can use also
selective laser centering.
Let's call it selective
laser scanning.
So you can have a
photosensitive polymer
and use a laser to cure that
and build up a honeycomb type
structure.
And you can also cast
honeycomb structures.
So those rubber honeycombs
that I pass around, those
are made by casting.
You take a liquid silicone
rubber and you add a hardener
and you pour it into a mold.
Another kind of interesting way
that people have made-- well
here's another example
of the honeycombs
that are 3-D printed.
And this is an example
of-- or a couple
of examples of looking
at a bio carbon template.
So what that means is
that these materials are
based on the wood, but none
of them are actually wood.
So what they do is they take
wood, like they take pine,
or they take beech or something.
They take some kind of
wood and they carbonize it.
So that they do the
same processes as
used for making carbon fibers.
So you put the wood in
an inert atmosphere.
And you pyrolyze it.
You heat it up to I
think 800 degrees C.
And all you're left
with is the carbon.
And it preserves the structure.
And you replicate the structure.
You just get the same structure.
There's some shrinkage.
The shrinkage is about 30%.
But you get the same
structure as the wood.
So this material up here
is actually all carbon.
It's just replicating
the wood that was used,
the pine that was used.
An then what people
have been doing
is using that carbon structure
and then infiltrating
that with gaseous silicon.
And they form silicon carbide.
So these structures down
here are all silicon carbide
replicas of wood.
And they're thinking about
using that for things
like filters for
high temperatures
or for catalyst carriers.
And one of the
attractive features
is wood has fairly small cells.
The cells around
50 microns across.
And so you get a
large surface area.
And this is a
similar thing here.
These two are the
carbon template.
And here they've used
silicon and they've actually
filled in the voids.
And so they've got
silicon carbide
where the cell walls used to be.
And they've got silicon
where the void used to be.
So people are playing
around with this
is another way of making a
honeycomb type of structure.
And they use other kinds of
plants besides wood as well.
But that's the kind
of general idea.
So the idea is that wood has
a honeycomb like structure.
And the cells are fairly small.
the cells are in the order of
50 microns sort of in diameter
and maybe a few
millimeters long.
And this bio carbon template
replicates the wood structure.
So the wood is pyrolized
at 800 degrees C
in an inert atmosphere.
So say an inert gas.
And that gives you the
bio carbon template.
And you maintain the
structure, although there's
some shrinkage.
structures
And then this carbon structure
can then be further processed.
So for example, you
can infiltrate it
with a gaseous silicon.
And you end up with a
silicon carbide wood replica.
So possible applications are
things like high temperature
filters, or catalyst carriers.
I think that's it
on the honeycombs.
Are we good with all
sorts of methods?
And my little talk
here on processing
is certainly not comprehensive.
I'm sure there's other
ways people have developed.
These are some main ways.
All right then, I want to
talk about foams as well.
People have developed
different types of processes
for different types of solids,
so polymers, and metals,
and ceramics.
So I just go through each class
of solid and talk about that.
So the idea with
polymer foams is
that you want to
introduce gas bubbles
into either a liquid
monomer or a hot polymer.
And then you want
the bubbles to grow.
And then you want to
stabilize them and solidify it
by other cross linking or
by cooling the hot polymer.
So there's a variety
of ways of doing that,
but let me just put that down.
So there's a few ways to
get the bubbles in there
in the first place.
One, is just by
mechanical stirring.
So if you've ever
made meringue, you
know what that is,
you just take a whisk
and you beat egg
whites and bubbles.
The air will get enveloped
in the egg whites.
They also do that with polymers.
Or you can use a blowing agent.
And there's several
varieties of blowing agents.
So the blowing
agents are divided
into physical and
chemical blowing agents.
And the physical ones,
they force the gas
into solution under
high pressure,
and then you reduce
the pressure,
and the gas bundles expand.
So you can use physical
blowing agents.
Or you can introduce
liquids that, if you're
using a hot polymer, that at the
temperature of the hot polymer,
they form a gas.
So that the liquid
just turns into a gas.
And that would
form vapor bubbles.
And then the chemical
blowing agents.
There's a couple of different
ways that those work.
You can either use
chemical blowing agents
where you have two parts that
react together to form a gas.
And so that gas
then blows the foam.
Or you can have a
chemical blowing
agent that reacts
with the polymer
to form a gas and
that blows the foam.
So either way.
And you can have them
decompose on heating.
So the same kind of thing.
Evolved the gas when it
gets into the hot polymer.
So there's these different
ways of blowing the foams.
And there's many, many different
types of these blowing agents.
But, these are kind of
the general techniques.
And whether or not the foam
forms an open cell or a closed
cell structure depends
on the rheology
of the polymers, so
the viscosity of it,
and also the surface tension.
Another way to make a
foam is to make something
called a syntactic foam.
A syntactic foam
is made by taking
thin walled hollow
spheres and then using,
say a resin, like an epoxy
resin, to bond them together.
So you end up with
something that's porous.
And you've got the void
from the hollow sphere,
but you don't foam
it in the same way
that you blow bubbles
through it in some way.
One other thing
about polymer foams
is they sometimes have
a skin on the surface.
So when you blow them,
say you've got a mold,
there will be a skin that
forms against the mold,
and sometimes the process
is designed in a way
that the skin is
thick enough that it
acts like a skin in
a sandwich panel.
So they control the mold in
a way and the blowing process
so that they get a foam in
the middle and thicker skins
on the top and the
bottom surface.
And that forms a sandwich panel.
Those are called
structural foams.
Let's see.
So I think what I'm going to
do next is the next section's
on metal foams.
And I've got a few
slides on that.
So I think I'm going to
run through the schematics
and just talk about it.
But, I'll put the notes
on the board next time.
And there is one thing I
forgot to do at the beginning.
I like to tell you
a little about me.
And I want to hear about you.
So I wanted to leave a
few minutes for that.
So let me just wait
until people are
finished writing stuff down.
And I'll go through
these in a few minutes,
and then we'll through it
in more detail next time.
And I'll write notes down.
OK?
Are we good?
So there's a whole variety of
ways of making foamed metals.
And most of them have
been focused on aluminum.
But you could in theory do them
with other types of metals.
So this was one of
the first processes
and it just involved
taking a molten aluminum,
so here's the aluminum
down here in a crucible.
They added silicon
carbide powder to it
and then they just
used a stirring paddle,
like they just stirred it up
and mixed gas in that way.
And they found that they
got bubbles that rose up.
And then they used
conveyor belts
to just kind of
pull the foam off.
And the thing about
the silicon carbide
was that if you
didn't have that,
then the bubbles
wouldn't be stable enough
that you could do this.
The bubbles would
collapse before you
got to be able to pull them up.
But the silicon carbide I think
makes the aluminum melt more
viscous and it helps prevent
sort of drainage and collapse
of the bubbles.
And so that's one way.
And there's a type
of foam called Cymat,
and this is an example
of the foam that's
made with that process.
Maybe I'll bring it next time
and we can pass it around.
Another method is to use a metal
powder and titanium hydride
powder.
Then you can consolidate that.
So here's-- it's hard
to see the writing,
but this is a aluminum powder.
This would be the
titanium hydride powder.
You mix them together and
then you compact them.
You press them together.
And the titanium hydride
decomposes and forms
the hydrogen gas
at a temperature
at which the aluminum
is not really
quite molten but it's kind of
viscous-y, kind of softening.
And so when the aluminum is
soft like that and the titanium
hydride decomposes and
forms the hydrogen gas,
you get a foam
from that process.
And I think, somewhere,
yeah, this foam here
I think was made
by that process.
Then in a similar thing, you
can just put titanium hydride
powder into molten aluminum,
and again the titanium hydride
powder evolves the hydrogen
gas and you get foamed aluminum
from that.
And I think this foam here
was made with that process.
They all look kind of similar.
Another method is by replicating
an open cell polymer foam.
So I think I passed an open
cell polymer foam around.
And that's made by taking an
open celled-- an open cell
aluminum foam-- it's made by
taking an open cell polymer
foam, you fill up all
the voids with sand.
You then burn off the
polymer, but now you've
got sand in all the sort of
places where there were voids.
And then you infiltrate
molten metal into that.
And then you get
rid of the sand.
And then you're left
with an aluminum
foam that replicates the polymer
that you started off with.
So this replication technique.
There's a vapor
deposition technique.
And this was developed by
Inco to make nickel foams.
So they take again an
open cell polymer foam,
that's kind of this thing here
is, and they infiltrate into it
nickel CO4.
The only teeny detail that's
a problem with this process
is that happens to
be highly toxic.
So they put this
gas through here.
And then they get nickel
depositing on the polymer
and they burn the polymer
out and they center it.
So it is possible to do this.
They have done this.
But it's not that
practical because
of the toxicity of the gas.
Now another method is something
called entrapped gas expansion.
And here, what you do is you
take a can, like a metal can.
This one's titanium,
a titanium alloy.
And then you put a
titanium powder in here.
You evacuate the can.
So the can has a little valve
on it, so you can evacuate it.
And then you backfill
it with argon gas
and you pressurize
the argon gas.
So you've got a powder with
sort of pressurized gas
inside of a can.
And then you hot
isostatically press it.
So you heat it up and
you press it uniformly
in all three directions.
And you compact it.
And then, if you
want you can roll it.
Sometimes people
roll it because they
want to make sandwich
panels, and they
want to have a
certain thickness,
and they want to have
faces on the panel.
But then you heat that up.
And as you heat it up,
the gas evolves again.
And the thing expands and
you get a foam that way.
So that's another method.
Another method is by
making hollow spheres
and then bonding the
spheres together.
And in this process-- this
was developed at Georgia Tech.
They used the titanium
hydride again.
They made a slurry of
the titanium hydride
in an organic
binder in a solvent.
And then they had a
little kind of needle
that they injected gas.
And so they had this slurry
and they were blowing gas
through this needle and they got
hollow spheres of the titanium
hydride.
And then they heated it up, and
again evolved the hydrogen gas
off.
But now they're just left
with titanium spheres.
And then they bonded
the spheres together.
And these aren't titanium.
This is an iron
chromium, like it's not
quite a stainless steel.
But this is the same thing.
I can pass that
around next time too.
Those are the little
beads that they make.
And then there's also
fugitive phase technique.
So you can take say salt
particles, put them in a mold
and pour a liquid
metal into that,
and then, leach the salt away.
And I think that's it
for the metal foams.
So I think I'm going
to stop there for today
in terms of the lecture.
I'll go over that
again next time.
And I'll write
stuff on the board.
But I wanted to tell
you a bit about me.
So the people in
3032, they already
know me because they
had me in the fall.
But I see some unfamiliar faces.
So I thought I would tell
you a little about me.
So I grew up in Niagara Falls
in Canada, big power station.
Lots of big civil engineering
works in Niagara Falls.
And my father worked at
an engineering company
that specialized in the
design of hydroelectric power
stations.
It was founded by the guy who
designed the Niagara Falls
power station.
And then I went to
university in Toronto.
And I did a degree in civil
engineering in Toronto.
And then when I finished my
degree in civil engineering,
I wasn't really sure
what I wanted to do next.
And I applied for some jobs, and
I applied to graduate school.
I applied to MIT.
And I didn't get in-- ouch.
But I did OK, it turns out.
And I ended up-- I
had an advisor when
I was in Toronto who had taken
a sabbatical in Cambridge,
England.
And he said he thought I might
enjoy Cambridge, England.
And I ended up going
to Cambridge, England
to doing my PhD there.
And I worked on the
cellular solids for my PhD.
And it was a nice
combination because I
was interested in material
behavior and mechanics,
but I had a background in
me in civil engineering.
And these are just like
civil engineering structures,
but they're on a little
teeny weeny scale,
not like big buildings
or bridges or something,
like little teeny things.
And really all of
this has come out
of doing that PhD in Cambridge.
But when I was there,
I never even thought
about being an academic.
And I never applied
for any academic jobs.
I didn't think I wanted
to be an academic.
And I went and got a job in
Calgary in the oil business.
And I was working at
a consulting firm that
did work for the oil business.
I hated it.
I just hated it.
It was like I had a boss.
I hated having this boss.
And, you know, the projects
were too short term.
The winter in Calgary--
if you think this is bad,
you've seen nothing.
Like less snow, but cold.
I mean like 30, 40
below, everyday, cold.
Real cold.
So I stayed there one winter.
And somewhere along
the way there, I
decided maybe the academic
job thing would be good.
And I just sent my CV out to a
bunch of Canadian universities.
And I ended up getting a job
at the University of British
Columbia in Vancouver.
And I lived in
Vancouver for two years.
And I probably would
have stayed there,
except there was a
gigantic recession,
and it was all very depressing,
and there was no money.
And that the
universities in Canada
are almost all run by the
provincial governments.
And the government had no money.
It was all, you
know, frustrating.
And I sort of thought,
oh, I'll look around
and see what else I can get.
And I answered a little ad
in Civil Engineering Magazine
for a job at MIT.
And I got the job at MIT.
And I was in the civil
engineering department
for about 12 years.
And then I moved over to
the materials department.
Because my work started
off on sort of sandwich
panels and structural things.
And then it kind of became
more biomedical stuff
and had less and less
to do with civil.
And I've been in the materials
department since then.
And this is kind of what
I do, this kind of work.
So that's kind of my
little five minute story.